things are meant to be local
and when you give into something and you
put your heart into something that's
local um then you can bless locally and
do more stuff with the local community
and so if you spread out things and make
it too big that money just seems to
float away into nothing
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bringing to you the awareness that
you need to know about the violence on
the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as possible to build
a community center on this much needed
block called o block it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs took the o in his name and
started calling it o block we decided
we're going to keep the o but we're
going to change it to opportunity block
i want to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity every day to bring to you
rooftop revelations where i share with
you my thoughts viewpoints and opinions
on matters as it relates to chicago and
issues across our great country i am so
grateful today to have a special guest
and he's going to spend some time with
us tonight he's taking our ceo challenge
his name is michael martin and he is the
managing partner of up stack and uh he's
here from the sunshine state of florida
so we're really appreciative of him
being here uh mike welcome thank you
thank you very much so how's it feel
being in this uh cold weather from
florida it's it's chilly it's chilly it
feels all right but my eyes a little
water
listen i always start off the
conversation by asking people you know
why are you here you know you can be
somewhere else but you're here on the
south side of chicago uh on a rooftop
going to sleep tonight in a tent in a
sleeping bag in this cold
why is that
you know um
back on december 5th i
opened up my uh news thing in the
morning and fox news by the way it was
on fox news
on my app and i and i read about you
coming back up here on this roof and i
thought what is that nutty pastor doing
again um i remembered you from 10 years
ago when you did this
and
i uh i went and talked to my mom my my
mom excuse me my wife yeah and we were
chatting a little bit i said hey i think
this is something we could do i knew
that my company was about to be sold and
i wanted to bless somewhere and i just
said you know i think this is a good
organization and we should go after it
well thank you man listen you know
there's a lot of great organizations but
what made you say you know what i'm
going to help project hood
part of it was
the whole challenge of coming up here
and
not just
you know throwing some money out there
and and yet actually being able to jump
in and being involved with something and
learning more about the organization and
and other things that i could do in the
future right right so we we're really
appreciative and um of you doing that
and we've talked a little bit um before
now and we talked a little bit about
government and spending and taxation
and why is it important do you believe
that from your point of view that
organizations like ours
are
are given more
as far as time and resources as it
relates to
giving it to the government
i think a big portion of it is just that
things are meant to be local
and when you give into something and you
put your heart into something that's
local um then you can bless locally and
do more stuff with the local community
and so if you spread out things and make
it too big that money just seems to
float away into nothing and um even
though chicago is not local for me i'm
here a lot for business and um you know
i've i've grown to love the city and um
i just i i think keeping it local and
doing it here is the way to go yeah well
we really appreciate it you know
and
when we when we issue the ceo challenge
never in our wildest dreams that we
think that
brothers like you from florida would say
hey i'm gonna go help him out but we
really appreciate it and i'm sure just
like you were watching um there are some
other people who are watching and
they're trying to make a decision about
what to do why why do you think this is
a good thing for ceos to participate and
why take the ceo challenge and get
involved in the work of project hood
well
i think the biggest thing is i did some
research right off the bat i met with
your team i didn't just make the
decision and say hey you know let's go
just throw them some money yeah um and
so we had some good conversations about
not only
just the whole work just the whole work
of project code what you already have
going on and what you started 10 years
ago the impact that's made in this
community um and the impact that's going
to happen in the future um based on this
community center being built um and it's
it's awesome man it's just going to be
killer yeah well we thank you and
appreciate it you know
that's what it's really all about having
people from across the world
understand that listen as americans
if we work together we can make things
happen we can do some important things
to help a lot of people
and sometimes it's the stronger parts of
america to help with some of the weaker
parts of america
and
in the process i think we all gain
something out of it so i want to thank
you for coming here thank you for
spending the night tonight i hope you
don't freeze
and uh thank you for being a part of our
rooftop revelations thank you man
appreciate it listen it's always a
blessing i am so extremely grateful to
fox for giving me this opportunity every
single day to bring to you rooftop
revelations but i also want to thank eli
steele for writing up everything and
producing our show thank you to terrell
for
the camera work and making sure that we
give you all good footage and making
sure that everything runs smoothly but
as always fox i appreciate you thank you
thank you for another rooftop
revelations and until tomorrow
peace